hello everyone and welcome to another
game you requested it's from the 1962
chorus all candor this tournament we
were already shown Paul Anka vs. Bobby
Fischer a very nice victory by Paul
Banquo with the Banco opening or the
Hungarian opening the g3 move and a lot
we said that you would like to also see
his game against Michael Tao and well
let's just enjoy it we've had we haven't
covered the 1962 chorus all candidates
I'm planning to cover it at some point
maybe as a part of the Tigran Petrosian
saga as this is a candidates tournament
that leads to him to the Watchers
championship match but maybe as a
standalone tournament as it's such a
nice tournament but until I decide on
that let's just enjoy this game so Banco
with the white pieces again we have g3
at the Banco opening with g6 by Tom
Bishop the g-tube Bishop to g7 and d4 we
have d 6 by tau and now II for grabbing
the center with Knight to f6 and nice to
e 2 now we have castles by tall castles
by Benko
in the Knight B to d7 with an IBC 3 c6
and now a 4 so the position is similar
to the position Fischer had against
banco also in the in the chorus all
candidates
although Fisher's Knight was stolen b8
and Fischer had a pawn on e5 but what
Fisher allowed was for Banco to put this
pawn all the way to a5 whereas stall
doesn't allow a top pushes a5 himself
and he says that it's too strong at all
our whites to push a 5 that's ok Bank
who plays b3 similar indicator like in
the game against Fischer he wants to
develop this Bishop to a3 to assume this
strong diagonal and rook to e8 by tall
with Bishop to e3 and now Queen to c7
and it's interesting this position has
never happened again after it was played
in this game so Queen to d2 babenco
preparing to connect rooks and only now
II five by tal net now that he really
controls the e-file but of course banco
ignores it with rook 8 d1 and now he
captures on d4 with Knight captures on
d4 and now knife to c5
now finds an excellent outpost for this
night and c5 as white will be unable to
put b4 due to the a five point all
pushed and also white doesn't have a
deep one to kick it away and it's very
unlikely that you will give up your dark
square Bishop for this night so an
excellent outpost for the night with f3
strengthening the e4 pawn and now b6
towel is not ready to develop the light
square bishop as well with Knight D back
to e - now the Queen and rook are ready
to capture on d6 so Benko has the tile
has to defend in some way
now you could defend it with rook to d8
but tal is greedy Hall says I already
developed this rook to e8 I want to play
Bishop b7 maybe Bishop day six and bring
this rook over to d8 without wasting any
time so first he defends it with the
bishop to f8 but now with Bishop to f8
this Bishop no longer controls this
excellent diagonal so Banquo transfer
hit his own Bishop to this excellent
diagonal with Russia back to be - Queen
to e7 by tau this is a this is an odd
move I haven't really seen the idea
behind Queen to e7 Bishop to be some
fall by rook a to d8
as he planned seems to be the way to go
but he prefers Queen to e7 and the
banquet egg he takes this opportunity to
get his knight into the game with Knight
d4 Knight to f4 was also a possibility
but he plays Knight to d4 as the Queen
no longer guards the c6 pawn but this
doesn't really bother at all as he was
planning to develop the bishop to b7
either way so Bishop to b7 and now the
knight also blocks the Queen's attack
towards the d6 pawn so tall doesn't have
to worry about that
with rook F 2 e 1 and now Bishop to g7
now the bishop can get back to this
strong diagonal as the pawn is not in
danger of being captured with f4 by
Benko and now finally rook 8 d 8 tall
manages to get his a rock to d8 as
planned
Bishop to f3 now controlling the G for
square not allowing the Black Knight to
go there and also making room for the
king or the Queen to occupy the g2
square we have Queen to d7 by tau
and now if you don't want to allow some
queen to age three ideas a banker
prevented with the Queen to g2 and d5
Todd would be very happy if he can just
trade everything on d5 make his
LightSquared bishop come alive but bank
of course is not interested in that he
says we're just gonna keep the center
closed we have E 5 pushing the night
back night after efore and now it seems
like tall is offering a pawn but he's
really not back banker trades once with
night chapters and D captures and now
even though it seems like you can
capture here he really can't because if
you capture you just get tonight
captures it doesn't really matter what
you capture the night with let's say
queen capture c5 just wins the game as
now you either lose the queen of course
you're gonna move the Queen but then you
lose the night so you're gonna be down a
piece so after D captures on e4 Bank or
doesn't fall for it he plays better back
to e to and now Queen back to e7 getting
the Queen away from this D file as it's
really just not really doing all that
much here and now banco brings the
bishop back Bishop to e3 so really nice
maneuvering with the bishop by Banco
first a3 then returning to be 2 when the
B two diagonal became more important
then now returning it to a3 pinning the
night Estelle's queen is now on e7 and
here tall probably should have gone
Queen to c7 even on the previous move
Queen to c7 was better just not just Oh
Bishop to e3 doesn't do anything but
even here just retreating with Queen to
c7 is best but here top played f6 now is
this one of those positions where it's
actually okay to play f6 well you will
decide as you will pause the video here
and try to find the best continuation
for banco in this position well I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
Punishers a Punisher of an f6 move that
when it's not okay to play it in a
position and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show Bishop to c4
check and now of course you see that you
cannot interpose with the night as the
knight is pinned you will lose the Queen
you cannot go King to f8 because just 96
check pretty much ends the game so top
played King to h8 and now Knight
six just the same as the night still
cannot be captured due to the pin you
have to move the rook the problem is and
well once this dark square Bishop gets
eliminated and it will be eliminated
this Bishop will once again return to
this Square and then banker will have
these well we can say it a nice bishop
pair from hell
so rook the d5 tall decided it was
better just to give up the rook that way
for example if you play something like
rook captures rook captures then there's
there's not a good move
once the knight capture series you're
just gonna bring the bishop to be -
you're gonna capture on f6 open up this
diagonal and it's just game over so tall
decided to give up the the exchange with
rook to d5 to at least get rid of one of
the bishops so bingo said okay so it's
it's a nice rook I will have it Bishop
captures and v5c captures and now of
course you are getting rid of the dark
square Bishop Knight captures and g7
King captures and g7 and now pawn
captures with check with Queen captures
on f6 now not allowing Bishop to b2 as
the Queen now guards the b2 square but
it's not a problem
Queen to f2 you don't want to allow
something like III and D fort for
thought Frieda's bishop so Queen to f2
not allowing III and now Knight back to
e6 now tall he's not in the exchange but
he does have a strong center and if he
can push d4 and e4 in d3 and if this
bishop comes alive it could become very
dangerous for banco so here at all is
saying basically well bluffing actually
that banco cannot capture on b6 that
it's too dangerous but banco says I'm
not tricking you I know I know you're
your style I'm just gonna capture it
because this is a nice free pawn so he
played Queen captures and b6 and now of
course Thal has to do something about
the bishop he he plays Bishop to a8 and
now we have Bishop to d6 by banco banco
is not preparing Bishop to e5 to win the
Queen here so I'll just gives the Queen
out of the way we have Queen to f5 now
already
again if tau can get these two moves in
then the bishop
Queen there there might be sorry there
might be something here but Queen
captures an a5 Banquo just grabs another
pawn he says there's nothing there
Tao moves the King even further to
safety we have King to h6 and now
finally see for starting to put the
pawns because if you capture then Queen
kept just a nice Queen trade but as Bank
was up in material talk another for the
Queen trade so look back to d8 attacking
the bishop and now Bishop to e7
attacking the rook and also preparing
Bishop to g5 if needed this will come
with check so thought says okay here
it's all or nothing III tell just pushes
the pawn and he asks are you may be
interested in a nice rook on d8 and well
could you capture it sure you could
capture it there isn't all that much
poison there but there there's no need
to give tile more than you need because
a lot of players did this and you know
it always goes wrong
so just rook captures and III just
getting rid of that pawn and getting the
roof - uh well I'm more useful Square
we've looked back - eh now the rook
overstayed its welcome on d8 and now
Bishop to g5 check of course any trades
are not in your favour now the rock on
e8 is unguarded so here we have King
back to g7 by tal and now rook DT one
bank who claims the e-file for himself
and again tells us it's all or nothing
Knight captures on g5 Todd tries giving
up the rook on the 8th for some knight
of three action and even though you
could capture it all night f3 check it's
really hard to do
- actually blunder the game even if
something like King g2 Knight captures
anyone with check rook captures and this
you deliver this check in hopes of
picking up the Queen and a5 it doesn't
worry because just Queen captures on a8
so it's very hard to blunder this game
but you're playing against all you don't
want to you know complicate it too much
so he just played F capture son g5 and
tal now plays rook to f8 so tall now has
decent pressure along the F file and if
he manages to free the lights for Bishop
still tile maybe could could do
something but banku here played Quinta a
seven check and in fact it was in this
position that me Hotel resigned the game
on move 41 as there really is nothing
more to do here because once the King
moves you can go here now the point is
guarding that square we have to go to g8
or H a doesn't really matter for example
King to h8 if you block with the rook of
course you lose the bishop would check
so if King to h8 you're just getting
rook to e7 and there's no defense just
rook captures on h7 is coming and with
the Queen and a7 you also guard the f2
square so there isn't you can't even do
a nice little check on f2 so yeah I
think I'm gonna use this as a thumbnail
as it's really nice but yeah a very nice
victory bug pal Benko defeating Fischer
defeating tall he loves a big ball
carries in this tournament so it was a
very nice tournament for banco and like
i said at one point we will cover the
1962 coração candidates tournament even
either as a part of the Tigran Petrosian
saga or as a standalone tournament we're
gonna we're gonna see how it goes
but yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and I would like to apologize
for not mentioning it was a mate in 3 in
the previous video that's the price you
pay for not showing all that many
puzzles I just completely it just
completely slipped my mind but you know
looking on the bright side of things you
know it's very unlikely that I will make
such a mistake again so that's that's a
plus I guess but yeah like I said that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Emily boys Gabriel
Frechette I'm Ryan Stephenson Daniel
Moore and of insertion abating for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos ER think all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the Capablanca saga we are
now going after that and we're going to
finish it and then just checking up in
your suggestions and of course whatever
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day